how you es una ex periodista de
investigación la más famosa de china
ahora está retirada ejerció su profesión
durante 40 años
este libro es una colección de artículos
que escribir sobre el 4 de junio de 1989
junio de 1989 la masacre de la plaza
tiananmen por sus investigaciones y su
postura a favor de la libertad de
expresión ya ha pasado tres periodos en
prisión siete años en total trabajar
como periodista en china nunca ha sido
fácil pero gao yu reconoce que el
control de los medios de comunicación es
aún más estricto hoy que cuando era
periodista
el control y la censura se han reforzado
considerablemente hoy en día es casi
imposible publicar artículos o
comentarios libremente puedo decirles
que la censura es mucho más fuerte hoy
que hace tres años hoy en día los
periodistas no tienen más remedio que
transmitir la palabra del partido
comunista chino este es un paso adelante
particularmente visible desde el
comienzo de la epidemia de coronavirus
en china no tuvimos acceso a la deuda de
la mayoría de los reportajes publicados
elogiaron al gobierno y lo felicitaron
por su acción 300 periodistas chinos
fueron enviados por el gobierno central
de aguja pero no sabíamos lo que
realmente estaba pasando
la información está bajo control y los
periodistas de investigación están
desapareciendo había 500 hace 10 años
hoy hay menos de 100 desde que si
jinping llegó al poder en 2012 los
medios de comunicación han estado al
servicio de la propaganda del régimen
más que nunca
el anterior presidente había aceptado
tácitamente cierta libertad en los
medios de comunicación no era una
libertad total pero había algo de esta
ahora bajo la dirección de chilling pink
todos los medios de comunicación incluso
la prensa y la publicidad del pueblo
deben cumplir con los requisitos del
partido
la censura no sólo afecta a los
periodistas profesionales las
autoridades también atacan a los
ciudadanos periodistas en wuhan el lugar
de origen del cobi 19 todos los que
intentaron documentar la crisis fueron
silenciados
y
el pasado mes de febrero el abogado se
incluso fue arrestado en internet
publicó vídeos grabados en wuhan como
este en este hospital de campaña
hoy en día nadie sabe dónde están y
thank you suit sigue desaparecido tres
meses después
jiang shan desaparece ella también era
abogada y periodista ciudadana fan bing
un comerciante también se esfumó
el gerente de una tienda de ropa en
wuhan estaba documentando el estado de
saturación de los hospitales sus vídeos
fueron vistos cientos de miles de veces
antes de ser censurados en este caso
cuenta los cuerpos envueltos en bolsas
en la parte trasera de un camión
hemos localizado a uno de sus amigos más
cercanos
zhang y también es comerciante en wuhan
era parte de un grupo que se dedicaba al
trabajo de investigación de fun wheel
no hizo nada ilegal cuando veo este
vídeo siento mucha emoción
probablemente fue arrestado por la
seguridad nacional donde está
exactamente no sabemos también hay otros
ciudadanos periodistas de quienes no
tenemos noticias
la censura de los periodistas ciudadanos
no es nueva en la epidemia este bloguero
ha estado pagando el precio desde 2014
desde que borraron mi primer blog en la
red social which are he creado 120 más
pero han sido borrados uno por uno en
sus artículos analiza las decisiones de
las autoridades textos que consideran no
subversivos pero que no son aceptados
por las autoridades ya no puedes
criticar nada en el pasado el gobierno
solía decir que la crítica podría llevar
al progreso hoy en día ya no podemos
decir nada ni siquiera una crítica
constructiva
en enero pasado escribió un balance del
2019 ya no tiene un blog donde
publicarlo así que intenta enviarlo
directamente a sus contactos pero el
control es tan estricto que el mensaje
no llega
y
mira estoy tratando de enviarte el
artículo que escribí pero no lo reciban
mira mi mensaje no aparece pero si
intentó enviar una cara sonriente si
pasa puedo seguir escribiendo pero es
como gritar de una pared todo lo que
escucho es mi eco censura arresto
detención según reporteros sin fronteras
china es la prisión más grande del mundo
para los periodistas hoy en día 114
defensores de la libertad de prensa
están detenidos en las cárceles chinas